Here's everything my German dad eats in a day,
slash what I cook for him.
Cooking is my love language,
so I love cooking for people that I care about.
I thought it would be nice to cook for my dad
while he's out here helping me.
So let's start off with breakfast.
We did an egg scramble with some chives on top,
and then also some heirloom tomato.
This tomato was gorgeous.
And then I also added some feta cheese,
since that's one of his favorite cheeses.
And then I plated it all up with
some of my homemade pickled onions and some rye bread.
My dad likes really simple meals,
and he doesn't wanna eat a lot of meat,
so that's what we're going for today.
I obviously need to have my midday beverage,
you guys know.
So today it was an orange Poppy,
and then I got started on lunch.
For lunch, we kept it really simple
with some roasted asparagus
that I seasoned with some olive oil,
salt, pepper,
garlic. And then I sliced up some garlic,
onions, and cherry tomatoes,
and also some fennel.
Once asparagus was halfway done,
I topped my fish with Calabrian chili and tomato butter
and pop that in the oven to
cook alongside the asparagus.
Sauteed all my tomatoes with the onions in the pan,
and then I topped it all with some herbs
and some olives.
This was so good,
and one of his favorite meals that he's had.
In a while, as an afternoon snack,
I made some banana bread with my whipped robus
honey butter
and then topped it with some raspberry sauce.
I also made.
Ended up having three plates of that.
And then after that
I got started on dinner.
I decided to make some naan bread with a lentil doll.
So I prep my nando
and then made a quick pickled cucumber salad
with some sumak.
Diced up my onions,
added them to the pan with some aromatics
and some tomato,
added all my spices to get them nice and fragrant.
Lentils, some coconut milk
and then I plated that with some turmeric,
rice and raita.
Think that's how you pronounce it.
My pickled onions,
the salad and then my fresh naan bread.